how's gun breath my name is Mira
welcome back to some more hot to the
moon that's what the game is called
we're going back in time
wait don't you dare don't worry sheesh
we're gonna charge this see I'm doing it
by the books I'm gonna charge this with
balls and that would go on back in time
bro Hulk smash that's perfect thing to
say when you go back in time Neil
seriously I'm trying to get into this
and you're ruining the mood
totally worth it all right let's go get
this is totally you go back in there ah
another puzzle which one is which I
don't see oh okay I think I got
this yeah this should be easy
Jania spins dusted again in the ideal
format - I don't think I got enough
credit for solid ok ok it's in a moment
though I guess it's the contract for the
building that they gotta some some sugar
like that anyway doesn't matter
oh I gotta turn up the volume a little
bit
what's going on here it's beautiful look
at this I mean the graphic doesn't have
to be advanced for a game to be
beautiful in my opinion like sunset and
fireplace and then Oh crikey Nutcracker
you aren't Australian who cares we're
like two hundred billion automated off
the ground is standing on a damn flag
whoa this jumped down it's not like you
can have be heard from here are you
kidding me it's a freakin skydive you
can't stay on here you can't get off god
I hate you what is happened I swear if
this block ha ha ha hey what the
was she just pushed him that's
not very nice what's going on here is
this when they came here ah
why were they abandon her like this
our apology just no longer needed no
longer needed by ships I mean you know
how it is but now that everything has
GPS and all night
[Music]
what's going on
I wish Black River
oh that's the momentum this place means
a lot to me too and I've been thinking
in our current state things have been
pretty stable if we say well in a few
years we could afford to build a house
on top of here it's going to be a switch
but we'll be able to see her from the
window
wait so they're talking about the
lighthouse in the morning at night would
always be nearby
and and we could walk here anytime
she'll never be alone again John but
what if the firehouse the fire well I'll
be able to watch over here every day
yeah we're world
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow good for them you gotta be kidding
me
you remember what happened don't you
it's like watching a train wreck Bandung
isn't any more important than any of the
moments leading to it the important
thing is that over here they are happy
at stake a big girl let's move on
[Music]
but that's outside
that's outside all right we got one ball
wait a minute they were referring to the
Lauda as as onion weren't they yeah
that's what I I suppose
then that river she declined treatment
for the sake of a lighthouse girl is
that had a bit too extreme I've seen
send you things in the course of the job
me too but uh I can never wrap my head
around it it's none of our business
anyway she's not our client okay let's
keep moving I guess we're going back in
time yeah there they are so that gives
us two balls I don't know why but I'm
thankful for the balls thank you thank
you game huh another ball and another
ball and we will unleash these balls on
this little bunny rabbit
I wonder what's up with those bunny
rabbit I want to know
I must know let's go wake up one back in
time back in ten Oh another puzzle
okay oh why can i just diagonalize from
here ah oh thank heavens
that was pretty terrible not gonna lie
sometimes it is so well and sometimes I
just can't for the life of me do this
puzzle but hey that's not what life is
about it
and settled about rabbits and Oh
hopefully we'll get to see what's up
with those freakin bunnies right now
okay he took nice moustache John River
nice I'm gonna get me one of those when
I'm like 40 I guess not so this is
before she got sick
wait we are before she's got sick I'm
stupid dear Lord not again
all right we got another one I guess we
gotta follow and downstairs I really
really really really really want to see
what's up with these the piano gotta be
one ball an old baby by the piano how
the heck did they move this thing
upstairs
who knows I bet it'll be a piece of cake
for the TARDIS that's the machine they
use I guess not really when you can't
even get it through its door hmm true
well that sums it moving pianos is a
death for everyone everybody it'll
probably take an entire episode to get
it inside I wouldn't mind seeing such an
episode me neither it sounds pretty epic
what are they gonna make an episode of
moving the piano I get the feeling new
boxes of plain paper uh-oh I think I
know what this going more of them
rabbits ah so this is when it started
probably you went out for a haircut
this early in the morning
[Music]
what are you making there
rabbits did you see the rabbit I left
for you yeah yeah
tell me about that rabbit huh it's
different from all the other rabbits
John can't you just understand already
describe the rabbit it was yellow what
else a bit puffy and
[Music]
well it's just a paper wrapping I don't
know how else to describe it what is she
doing you're acting strange River at
something wrong River something is wrong
girls are complicated the story moral of
this knocking I don't know about you but
I'm getting something worse deja vu
I think I know of her condition but this
is rather already meant for that what is
her condition I I don't I don't get it
you think she's do you perhaps who knows
but like you said she's not our client I
said I'm up the voices lets it
get what we're paid for and for over
with all right find more balls that is
what we do
[Music]
maybe there's buckets orange hair okay
so this is the day it started what did
you do John tell us what you did all
right
that's charges footballs does it make
sense and let's go back in time with the
platypus
I really don't get it though all right
what about this one yeah this is easy
see nail that
now you go platypus see let's go back in
time activate their klappa puss it's not
every day you get to say that side what
it ha
he knows how to drive cars
[Music]
what is going on platypus what are you
want that sprockets pointing his finger
against me okay
[Music]
I guess we just go back to the house it
probably not gonna be a house now oh
that gives us a ball yeah this is
probably before they build a house
well we already been before we built
down sorry I'm really stupid yeah
what is going on here don't let the
bushes stop you just keep going here we
go
all right this is where the house used
to be isn't it
the house that never should have been I
mean really what is is it about
unusually high and dangerous places that
attract people
acrophobia okay nice jump you too that
is weird
we need three more balls Prez they are
let the thought yet at fact Kevin
letting by the lion oh it's working now
the lighthouse is that is that why you
approached me back
yeah what about now I suppose it's just
a part of it look it was a long time ago
it's not too relevant now but is it said
I should tell you the truth what truth
what is the truth John
I could have tainted our I shouldn't
I shouldn't have tainted our first
meeting like that she's heartbroken
can't you tell I don't know what you did
John but if you're sick man what is that
a hacky sack can you throw this as far
as where onions at I don't know you want
me to try would you don't do it John
you're throwing your heart away go River
are you inside you get away from there
[Music]
thank I think this memory isn't far too
far from the last so he told her about
something that when they met and
apparently that made her I don't know
distant even more distance I think they
may be connected
ah I want to know okay maybe talking to
her why did she cut her hair anyway I
like long I breath we're gonna go back
in time another time the next episode
but like a favorite if you enjoyed it
subscribe to come abroad today and I'll
see you next episode over a Bharani stay
awesome I know
I can't take it anymore
vespa joking right now
oh you we're actually fine we're
not fine stop Adama